In this lesson, we're going to talk about the U.S. healthcare system.
This is a complex topic that cannot be adequately covered in a single lecture.
So, I've provided suggested readings.
Some students wonder why I devote an entire lesson to
the US health care systems structure and economics in what is after all,
a health informatics course.
Many Georgia Tech students come to
this course with little background in the health care delivery system.
Health Informatics, the focus of this course is
the application of information technology to that delivery system.
I believe you need at least a basic grounding to appreciate the nature of
the system and the key roles Health Informatics can play in solving its problems.
To give some examples,
informatics can help avoid medical errors that often arise from inadequate information,
or the presence of more information than a human being can process.
It can help identifying reduce waste to unnecessary, or duplicative services.
It is critical to the surveillance of food borne analysis and disease outbreaks.
Data mining and many analytic techniques
are increasingly being used to find new medicines,
new treatment protocols, and new methods for earlier diagnosis.
These are just a few of the potential informatics benefits to health care delivery.
But each of them depends to one degree or another on the ability to share digital data.
As you'll see, now that most hospitals and around half of all providers have adopted
electronic record systems data sharing and interoperability is now the focus.
So, this course is largely about interoperability and
the role that the new HL seven fire standard plays in creating it.
To get ready for that,
we'll first discuss the US healthcare system and its problems.
And then, we'll begin the discussion of the role in
interoperable informatics landscape can play in solving them.